au dessus de l'export de céréales
ukrainienne se poursuit avec le départ
hier de deux navires chargés et de 70
000 tonnes de céréales à Odessa
l'envoyer spécial de France 24 Mélina
Huet est allée à la rencontre des
agriculteurs sur place et vous le verrez
certains ont du mal à écouler leur
production écoutez
pierre nous nous sommes rendus à une
soixanteaine de kilomètres de la ville
d'Odessa dans la campagne de cette
hoblaste du même nom et nous avons
rencontré notamment Vladimir 70 ans qui
n'a pas une petite ferme mais qui a une
ferme intermédiaire 300 hectares de
culture de diverses céréales et qui nous
expliquaient et bien que depuis l'année
dernière et surtout depuis le 24 février
il a du mal à vendre ne serait-ce qu'un
grade de ces céréales lui qui cultivent
du blé de l'orge mais également des
graines de tournesol il nous a fait
visiter son entrepôt ou encore 260
tonnes de ces céréales de la récolte
précédente et de celle de cette année
sont encore là au sol gise certaines
sont en train de pourrir absolument
aucune possibilité pour lui et bien de
vendre quoi que ce soit à l'étranger
alors même que depuis une semaine vous
l'avez dit les navires quittent le port
les trois grands ports d'Odessa et
finalement il nous expliquait que c'est
cette reprise des navires qui quittent
au dessin et bien elle profite surtout
aux grosses coopératives et lui a
beaucoup de mal il doit encore payer ses
factures il doit encore payer une partie
de son personnel l'essence évidemment il
n'a aucune rentrée d'argent il est très
inquiet le directeur adjoint du port de
décès qui nous avons pu parler hier nous
disait que l'inquiétude elle vient du
fait qu'il y a encore 20 millions de
tonnes de céréales qui sont dans des
silos dans des entrepôts dans l'oblastes
de décès qui a une nouvelle récolte qui
va arriver et ils attendent de 20 à 25
millions de tonnes supplémentaires de
céréales qui devront quitter le port
dans les prochains mois